The start of spooky season is right around
the corner but first, our favorite streaming
services need to let go of some titles to
make way for new content, and Netflix is no
exception.
These are the movies you won't want to miss
out on before they leave Netflix in October
2019.
The brilliant minds of Steven Spielberg and
Stanley Kubrick come together in A.I.
Artificial Intelligence, the 2001 sci-fi drama
Kubrick began developing in the late 1970s,
venturing to adapt Brian Aldiss' short story
"Super-Toys Last All Summer Long" into a feature
film.
In 1985, Kubrick teamed with Spielberg to
continue crafting the project, and when Kubrick
handed Spielberg the directorial reins a decade
later, he ran away with it.
What ended up on the silver screen was the
unique story of a childlike robot named David,
played by Haley Joel Osment, whose ability
to love and abandonment by his adoptive parents
set him on a journey to become a real boy.
It's one part The Adventures of Pinocchio,
one part The Wizard of Oz, and one part exploration
of a future, post-climate change world.
It's also got Jude Law as a male prostitute
named Gigolo Joe, so there really isn't anything
more you could want from A.I.
"I've picked up a lot of business in this
spot."
With two equally mind-boggling sci-fi horror
sequels having come out in the last three
years, it can be hard to remember where the
Cloverfield franchise actually began.
It started in 2008, before Dan Trachtenberg
pulled a last-minute twist in 10 Cloverfield
Lane and prior to Netflix's surprise release
of The Cloverfield Paradox, with the original
found-footage thriller helmed by Matt Reeves.
Cloverfield takes its name from the fictional
case in the movie known as "Cloverfield,"
an incident in which an enormous parasitic
creature and a horde of smaller monsters run
rampant through New York City, killing people
and destroying the city.
Presented as video clips that members of the
U.S. Department of Defense recovered from
a camcorder located in what was once Central
Park, the film follows a group of friends
as they attempt to evade the monsters and
make it out of the Big Apple alive.
Spoiler alert: Not all are successful in that
endeavor.
Cloverfield will remain on Netflix until October
1.
The stoner movie that might define all stoner
movies, Pineapple Express will sadly be leaving
Netflix before you know it.
Until that time comes, however, squeeze in
one more viewing of the buddy action-comedy
centered on a lazy stoner named Dale, his
dazed-and-confused dealer Saul, and his supplier
Red as they flee from hitmen and gangsters
after witnessing a drug lord and a crooked
police officer kill a man in cold blood.
Pineapple Express' silliness is what makes
the David Gordon Green-directed film so enjoyable.
It's made even better by all-in performances
from the whole cast particularly Franco, who
nabbed a Golden Globe nomination for his work
as Saul and a wonderfully quotable script
from Rogen and his longtime creative partner
Evan Goldberg.
"Only reason I started selling pot is so I
could put my bubbe in a nice retirement home."
Catch a ride on the Pineapple Express on Netflix
until October 1.
For horror lovers, October is the time to
watch at least one of the films in the Scream
franchise at least once per week.
Get a head start on that annual tradition
by working backwards with Scream 4, the 2011
franchise-closer that takes place during the
15th anniversary of the Woodsboro murders
from the original 1996 movie.
"What do you think?"
"Well, I guess today is the anniversary.
Kids."
Directed by slasher film icon Wes Craven,
Scream 4 sees Sidney Prescott returning to
Woodsboro with her publicist Rebecca Walters
as part of the tour to promote her new self-help
book.
Sidney gets a lot more than she bargained
for, of course, as she soon becomes a suspect
in a number of killings.
Things go from bad to worse when the masked
killer Ghostface begins calling Sidney's cousin
Jill and threatening her life.
As Sidney and Jill attempt to crack the case,
so too do Woodsboro sheriff Dewey Riley and
his wife Gale Weathers-Riley.
It's a fight against time, circumstance, and
traumatic history to rid Woodsboro of Ghostface
for good and Netflix subscribers have until
October 7 to find out how it all ends.
Directed by Norwegian filmmaker Morten Tyldum
and based on the Andrew Hodges-written biography
Alan Turing: The Enigma, 2014's The Imitation
Game tells the incredible true-life story
of British cryptanalyst Alan Turing, who worked
as part of the British government's cryptography
team during World War II and decrypted the
thought-to-be-unbreakable German codes transmitted
by the country's Enigma machine.
Throughout the course of the film, it's revealed
that Turing is gay, which was punishable by
law in England at the time and complicates
Turing's personal and professional lives.
The end of The Imitation Game will stir even
the steeliest of people leaving little question
as to why the film won an Academy Award in
2015, or why critics have praised it as, quote,
"a moving tribute to an extraordinary man."
The Imitation Game is available to stream
on Netflix until October 29.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.